hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast evaluation and comparison of
non derivative a shin and derivative a
shin tandem mass spectrometry methods
for analysis of amino acids acyl
carnitine and 16 l acetone in dried
blood spots I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to being
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots and sponsored by thermo
fisher scientific thermo fisher is a
world leader in serving science whose
mission is to enable customers to make
the world healthier cleaner and safer
thermo fisher scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increased laboratory productivity
more information please visit www fix
calm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in a Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or does make
your problem to the green Q&A button
lower left before I introduce today's
speaker we'd like to know a little
matter audience today and ask you to
respond to three short polling questions
your help is very much appreciated and
we will use this information to help
develop topics for future webinars for
first question is which kind of
organization are you from please check
the closest type of lab to yours and a
is inborn errors metabolism lab B is
reference lab see clinical research lab
the forensic toxicology lab
he is university hospital lab and F is
other and to me that again is in more
errors metabolism lab be is reference
lab see clinical research lab D forensic
toxicology lab the university hospital
lab and f is other you a minute to
answer that pole okay our next poll asks
which technologies are your lab
currently using and you can select
multiple choices here so a is LC ms b is
hplc c is GC ms b is immunoassay e is in
biochemical technologies f is TCR and g
is next-generation sequencing and
remember you can select multiple options
here
give you another minute to answer
okay and our next one is which
application for your lab curtain
constantly running and again you can
select multiple choices a is inborn
errors metabolism the forensic
toxicology see endocrinology research
the therapeutic drug research be protein
peptide quantification f is others and
remember again you can select multiple
options you know me cancer here
okay so thank you so much so your
speaker today is Jody fellow PhD senior
application scientists thermo fisher
scientific incorporated so the buffalo
earned his BS degree in clinical
chemistry at west chester university in
1977 in 1982 he received a PhD degree in
biological sciences from drexel
university in philadelphia during those
college years still work part-time
medical laboratory technologist at
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia for
most of the 20 years that followed
doctors booboo solo helped develop and
supported various analytical instruments
and software products for the perfect
elmer corporation in 2002 joe joined
cohesive technologies as an application
scientist cohesive was acquired in 2007
by thermo fisher scientific and joe
hardly works under the thermal umbrella
as a senior scientist training and
collaborating with customers and
managing the applications laboratory at
west chester university of pennsylvania
is also an honorary faculty member and
advisor in the university's
pharmaceutical product development
programs i will now turn it over to Joe
for presentation hello and thank you for
joining our webinar on analyzing dried
blood spots for researching inborn
errors of metabolism I'll be showing you
work done by application scientists
Cheryl easy under the direction of our
applications manager Marty Kozak this
presentation will help you decide
whether or not it is necessary to
derivative dried blood spot extracts in
order to measure various amino acids
acyl carnitine and succinyl acetone
bitanem mass spectrometry we will first
go through the technology that allows us
to make such measurements we will then
describe how a software product called
IRC Pro can process the data from each
specimen in order to study various
inborn errors of metabolism finally we
will cover the advantages and
disadvantages
using derivatives ation in preparing
dried blood spots for such applications
so let's start with mass spec technology
new developments in electrospray
ionization and tandem mass spectrometry
during the 1980s and 1990s allowed the
development of rapid high-throughput
analysis of samples extracted from dried
blood spots during this time professor
David Millington and his associates at
Duke University Medical Center use
tandem mass spectrometry to investigate
defects in enzymatic oxidation of fatty
acids in mitochondria such defects led
to the accumulation of acyl coenzyme a
intermediates that eventually leave the
mitochondria as acyl carnitine the duke
university researchers figured out how
to extract dried blood spots and how to
use tin and mass spectrometry to quickly
analyze these compounds by flow
injection without using chromatography
they eventually use tandem mass
spectrometry targeted to detect several
amino acids at the same time as they can
detect 20 acyl carnitine in order to
study over 30 metabolic diseases
including phenylketonuria or PKU and
here we show in the bottom center of
this slide an overview of one of our
newest triple quadrupole mass
spectrometers which was used in this
study the samples analytes first get
ionized in the source specific precursor
ions are isolated in the first
quadrupole that's the q1 mass filter and
selectively sent to the second q2
collision cell where they collide with
argon or nitrogen to form fragments
these product ions are then isolated in
the third quadrupole
which is the q3 mass filter and
selectively sent to the detector
specific transitions from precursor to
product ions are recorded and presented
by the mass spec software enabling us to
measure how much of each transition was
formed from our sample by mixing our
sample with a set of stable isotopes of
our analytes of interests the system can
measure the transitions of those as well
as the sample analytes themselves and
that allows us to estimate the amounts
of each analyte in our sample this
technique is known as isotope dilution
the compounds listed here include amino
acids succinyl acetone that's su AC and
then there's carnitine itself which is a
c0 and the various small chain that's c2
to c4 and medium chain c5 to c8 and then
there are the long chain and very long
chain that's the c10 to c 18 those are
the acyl carnitine and they get
extracted from the dried blood spots the
tandem mass spectrometry system can
measure these individual sample analytes
with high selectivity and sensitivity
enabling us to detect and quantify
multiple analytes from a single
injection into a flowing stream even
without derivatives ation the workflow
for doing such analysis is illustrated
here dried blood spots are punched and
the resulting discs are extracted with a
buffer containing internal standards
this part of the process can be
automated to utilize 96-well microtiter
plates the plates are then placed in an
LC system that automatically injects
extracts into a stream of solvent
flowing to the mass spectrometer in this
case the LC system does not utilize an
LC column instead we do flow injection
analysis so with each injection the mass
spectrometer applies ionization source
conditions as well as mass filtering and
collision induced dissociation
conditions that have been optimized for
each analyte and its internal standard
so that selective monitoring for each is
recorded and processed in addition to
the software used to control the
hardware and process the raw data from
the mass spectrometer in a generic
fashion we have a special software tool
called IRC Pro that you see over on your
right which takes that raw data and
automatically quantitate satellite
concentrations and performs custom
calculations such as analyte ratios in
order for analytes to be analyzed by a
mass spectrometer they must be ionized
the sensitivity of any mass spec method
is proportional to how many ions are
formed and how many of those ions get
into the mass spec some analytes are
already ionized with just one charge and
are easy to deal with others are not
amino acids and acyl carnitine Czar's
witter ions they have both positive and
negative charges that sort of cancel
each other out typically at ph values
from four to eight if we lower the ph
enough we can protonate the carboxylic
acid moiety of these molecules to make
them positively charged we could also
chemically modify these molecules using
butanol and HCL which converts
carboxylic acids to butyl esters this
derivatives a shin strategy ensures that
all of the analyte molecules are
positively charged in the mass spec
source and a larger percentage of them
are drawn into the quadruples earlier
models of mass spectrometers lack the
sensitivity to read
I ibly measure small amounts of such
analytes unless they are derivatives so
as we will see later in this
presentation the endurance sensitivity
is so good for amino acids and acyl
carnitine that derivatives ation is not
necessary the triple quad mass
spectrometer can selectively detect and
measure derivatized acyl carnitine and
amino acids by three different scan
modes at the top you see the neutral
loss scan looks for amino acids such as
the phenylalanine shown here that lose a
fragment with a specific mass of 102 and
that's actually butyl formate as you see
there the precursor ion scan next looks
for acyl carnitine that produce a
fragment with a specific mass to charge
ratio of 85 we also use SRM scans that
selectively or selected reaction
monitoring that look for specific
precursor ions that form specific
product ions for both derivatives and
non derivatives analytes the tsq endura
quadrupole mass spectrometer has a
unique design to achieve the best
sensitivity for all of the scan modes we
just mentioned for derivatives and non
derivatized analytes if we look at the
ion optics we have RF lens followed by a
bended ion beam guide with a neutral
blocker and then we have hyperbolic
quadrupole mass filter for q1 as well as
q3 and separating q1 and q3 is a curved
collision sell all these combined to
reduce noise and increase sensitivity
for enhanced quantitative performance
this is especially important when
introducing samples that have not gone
through extensive cleanup ultra-fast
selected reaction monitoring or SRM as
high as 500 s rms per second with up to
3
thousand definable s or ends in our
acquisition method this enables
quantification of more compounds in
shorter time frames and then at the end
here you see a five order magnitude
dynamic range of the Dino detector which
increases quantitative confidence so
with this unique design we believe we do
have the best-in-class sensitivity with
wonderful usability and of course
robustness that's needed for this kind
of application the unique design of our
mass filters which utilize hyperbolic
quadruples and a unique way the radio
frequency or RF is applied to them
result in a highly efficient
transmission of ions even at high mass
resolution and there are times when
sample matrix interferences are evident
in flow injection methods and since
chromatography is not used to resolve
those interferences switching the mass
spec to high resolution filtering for
the precursor ions becomes critical to
achieve selective detection and
quantitation and eliminating the
influence of any interferences the
unique design of the curved collision
cell enables SRM scan speeds of up to
500 srms per second with highly
efficient I on transmission if you are
using a mass spec with ultra
high-performance liquid chromatography
you get very sharp peaks and you need to
get at least seven points across the
sharpest chromatographic peaks in order
to integrate them properly however if
your scan limit is 200 s or as per
second which is the case in most triple
quads you are limited by how many
transitions you can measure
simultaneously if you don't use an LC
column and do flow injection analysis as
we do for acyl carnitine then this
performance becomes very necessary in
fact critical
if you don't have time or resources to
do extensive sample cleanup then you
risk contaminating the quadruples in the
mass spectrometer the data that you see
here is from making multiple injections
of pros m in synthetic serum our novel
ion optics design stops neutral
molecules from our sample from getting
into the quadruples thereby increasing
system uptime by three times over
previous designs this level of
reliability is especially important for
applications that utilize flow injection
analysis without chromatography the next
topic that we should cover is data
processing in addition to software used
to control the hardware of our LCMS
system which also collects the raw data
processes it and presents generic
qualitative and quantitative results we
use IRC Pro software to analyze the
results in more detail as you know
errors happen both random and systematic
following standard operating procedures
and utilizing hardware and software
tools to uncover and minimize errors
must be a priority in every laboratory I
will describe a software product that
reliably copies the data from our LCMS
system and performs the necessary
calculations and generates reports for
interpreting the results that software
is called IRC Pro which is made for
research use only as data is acquired by
our LCMS system IRC pro copies it and
does its own peak area integration here
we see a peak that was formed for the
SRM transition 209 to 107 from a flow
injection analysis of a specimen the
area under the curve is calculated by
specifying a percentile of the maximum
intensity
so that only in the intensities above
the noise level of the baseline get
integrated so we're able to integrate
this part very accurately and ignore the
rest which is attributed to noise after
determining the peak areas for analyte
using its SRM signals and for its
internal standard the software
calculates the concentration using a
relative response factor for that
analyte the IRC pro software can do
custom calculations such as adding and
subtracting and doing all sorts of
ratios for instance formula 1 is used to
investigate tarus anemia types 1 2 & 3
formula 2 is used to research
medium-chain acyl Caillat dehydrogenase
deficiency and formula 3 is used to
investigate carnitine uptake defect and
the IRC pro can do all these
calculations quite easily IRC pro is
easy to use first we program the
settings defining analytes analyte types
and sample types we then set up the
method which defines mathematical
formulas and concentrations finally we
process the mass spec data from LC or
flow injection analysis experiments as
they become available if our analysis
involves 19 compounds which include 10
sample analytes and 9 internal standards
and we were to run a batch of 480
samples IRC pro does the thousands of
calculations automatically without
transcription errors
to validate the IRC pro method we
compared its results to generic results
from the software use to control the
lcms system 49 analytes from 480
specimens we see excellent correlation
of the IRC pro results on the x-axis
with the generic results on the y-axis
the residual plots for both peak areas
and concentrations showed acceptable
dispersions or variances so the
variations here are nice and tight the
formulas that were automatically done by
RC pro were also validated by comparing
those results to manual calculations
done from spreadsheets which typically
take a lot of time and effort to do
again we get good correlations with
acceptable dispersions or variances
these are typical validation results of
our IRC Pro method that process results
from thousands of injections of
specimens containing the analytes shown
here out of 9120 peak areas almost
eighty eight percent that would be this
part here had a bias of less than five
percent out of 4800 concentration
calculations almost eighty five percent
how to bias of less than five percent
the custom formula we see here had a
bias ha of less than five percent for
all 480 calculations a more complicated
formula that you see down here involving
amino acids and acyl carnitine that had
a bias of less than ten percent 481
percent
the 960 calculations that were performed
so this formula stresses the system and
I really don't know many others who
would use such a complicated formula but
this was done to show you how we're able
to handle very complicated formulas by
IRC pro after covering the
instrumentation technology and software
used to acquire and process data we can
now focus on sample preparation the
question is do we need to derivatives or
not for this study amino acids acyl
carnitine and succinyl acetone we're
extracted from dried blood spot punches
using a single extraction step similar
to that of Dylan at all involving a seat
on I trial with twenty percent water and
zero point oh five percent formic acid
the derivatives approach involved butyl
ation of the carboxylic acid moieties of
each compound which takes an extra 45
minutes for the reaction and evaporation
of the beetle relation reagent this is
the LCMS system used to analyze the
prepared samples using flow injection
without chromatography the system
consisted of an ultimate binary uhplc
pump and an open acela auto sampler for
flow injections to the heated
electrospray ionization source of a tsq
indoor tandem mass spectrometer and of
course all of these are from thermo
fisher scientific the indoors mass spec
conditions you see here were optimized
for the amino acids succinyl acetone
carnitine and acyl carnitine also shown
are the flow injection parameters as we
injected ten microliters of sample into
a flow of acidified water in
acetonitrile solvent at 90 microliters a
minute the analysis time for each
injection was at one and a half minutes
so this permits a throughput of almost
40 samples per hour
these are some of the analytes and
internal standards that were used in the
study with their SRM transitions and
optimized mass spec parameters that is
collision energy and RF voltage to get
the best signals for the butylated
derivatives there were also 12 amino
acids succinyl acetone carnitine and 18
acyl carnitine in each sample these are
the corresponding parameters for non
derivatized analytes and internal
standards represented peaks from flow
injection analysis detected by SRM
transitions for succinyl acetone if su
AC and with terrell carnitine that's the
c5 c2 c 5 DC so that really is a
five-carbon dicarboxylic acid so along
with their internal standards you can
see that the detectors response for the
butylated su AC was over 30 times
greater than that for the non
derivatives su AC derivatizing the c5 DC
compounds increased response factor by
around five however the detective
responses for the non derivative
compounds were more than enough for
reliable quantitation also notice the
runtime of only one and a half minutes
per injection this is flow injection
analysis no chromatography needed which
means no abrasions no column washing so
this is very very quick we achieve a
throughput of 40 injections per hour one
question you may have is what is the
difference in lower limit of
quantitation between derivatives and non
derivatives amino acids as well as the
other compounds these methods are semi
quantitative and do not involve
calibration curves or loq values the
concentration of each analyte is
estimated from its peak area ratio de
gainst us in turn
standard peak area and then multiplied
by a response factor for the quality
control specimens low medium and high
and these specimens actually come for
the Centers for Disease Control here we
see for a derivatives sample set within
run precision was excellent and run to
run precision was very good the
concentration ranges in micro moles per
liter of these amino acids ranged from
65 to 290 that's micro moles per liter
for the low QC 152 400 for the medium QC
252 644 the hike you see and the range
is for the acyl carnitine were from
0.225 for the low QC 0.5 to 10 for the
medium QC and 1.0 to 15 and the hike you
see so that gives you an idea of what
kind of response factors that we're
getting the non derivatives sample set
also showed excellent within run
precision and good run to run precision
in fact if you look at the precision
numbers if you just go back and forth
for some of the compounds precision
numbers for the non derivatives batch
are often better than those for the
derivatives batch and that's something
that does happen when you do derivatives
a shin because you're adding an extra
step to the method even though we're
getting better sensitivity we're adding
an extra step and therefore we can add
more variants to our measurements so
that's not at all unusual
looking at the average precision of all
12 amino acids and 18 acyl carnitine we
see that differences between derivatives
and non derivatives sample sets were not
significantly different from each other
these precision values were very similar
to those achieved by Mets and others
from derivatized sample sets comparing
derivatives and non derivatized results
we see excellent correlation for the
amino acids and acyl carnitine results
even at low concentrations where
derivatives a shin is necessary if
you're using a less sensitive mass spec
the concentration ranges of many amino
acids were above 100 micro moles per
liter while those for the acyl carnitine
were less than 1 micro mole per liter in
conclusion the flow injection analysis
of dried blood spots for measuring
various amino acids acyl carnitine and
succinyl acetone can be done reliably
without derivatives ation using the t SQ
and Durotan on mass spectrometer also
our software tool IRC pro improves the
time effectiveness by eliminating manual
calculation processes and removing
transcription errors the method
differences between quantitative values
resulting from the two methods
derivatized versus non derivatized or
minor so it does show very clearly that
using the highly sensitive t SQ and dora
we don't have to derivatives we thank
you very much for attending this webinar
and we can now open this up for
questions and answer thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can dr. shell Lacey is an application
scientist from thermo fisher scientific
to do the research work for this
entation you will be joining doctors too
slow to answer your questions and our
first question is due to quadrupole mass
filters 21 and q3 have the same polarity
or alternated I think this question for
dr. sheet okay so this question are
actually for either q1 q3 cortical or
mac filter so each one basically has a
for loss and this follows actually have
two pairs of the priority positive and
negative and then so that means so each
particle has these two prodigies okay
and we'll be asking some more poll
questions during the Q&A and so our
first poll question is is your lab
running and inborn errors of metabolism
application and your choices are yes and
so can you want to keep it up you'll
move on to our next question again that
question it is your lab running an
inborn there's metabolism application
yes or no okay our next question in the
Q&A is to compare the pros and cons of
the two methods and you will pose that
question to dr ste so
as we can see from the presentation of
post method are highly correlated are
there are differences between these two
methods of the basically organization
method requires a lengthy Gill tights
process and the utilizes environmentally
unfriendly chemicals compared to you
typed methods market relation master is
rapid and the cost effective however the
rotating the resolution measure to
generate cleaner samples and high
signal-to-noise for analyte of interest
so it's very up to the users to choose
which method to use in your lab okay and
we're going to ask another poll question
right now and that is which topic do you
want to hear from us in the future first
need forensic toxicology and your
chronology research therapeutic drug
research multi-channel LC for example
prelude glx etc or software trace finder
tox finder etc and I'll give your mommy
to answer that if you moving to our next
question
okay in our next question is how much
difference of the signal in terms how
much as how much difference of the
signal when comparing the rivet ization
to nandi rivet ization method leave this
question is also for you dr. speak it
depending on the analytes verbalization
method increases the signal by anywhere
from three to forty times compared to
non derivatives methods trivet ization
methods would be the better choice if
you have a mass spectrometer that is not
as sensitive as some of the newer mass
spectrometers the thermo scientific tsq
indoor ms is sensitive enough for either
derivatives ation or non derivatives
ation methods okay and we have one more
poll question and then we'll be
answering more of your questions the
last poll question is do you think
today's webinar is helpful and the
choices are yes and no
give me a moment connects back move on
to our next question
okay what's poll question is have you
tried using an automated DBS system eg
DB SMS 500 from ta from JM AG for the
direct flow injection no we haven't
tried this automated dbf system but we
did so this presentation is kind of far
using menu temple processing okay next
question how can 90 realization direct
injection permit high analytical
specificity for complex sample analysis
so the patient sample preparation that
near us basically a little better
specificity because we will increase the
mass of analyte however the knowledge
has an answer it can also chief pretty
cool specificity although it cannot
although it cannot differentiate some
analyte with with the same are a mess
such as the are faithfully DC and the
c-4 hydroxide official actually in the
in practice somebody can use some curve
to mix some more calculation between
these ratios of this to analyze and can
still achieve there are the president
needs so I could argue that post method
can be can be can be used and generate
pretty reliable is out okay thank you
next question is how about the mythic
correlation for any specific analyte
so are minor differences one needs less
than fifteen percent they are observed
for the majority of analytes between the
two masses but we do have the
correlation graphs for each individual
analyte we monitored but we just don't
have so much room to show in this
presentation so if you want to say the
correlation for any specific analyze
please leave your email us and let us
know allocated certainly should the data
with you including expression is can t
SQ access be used instead of Endora yeah
the t SQ access is a much more
affordable triple quadrupole mass
spectrometer from thermo fisher
scientific and we've actually tested the
derivatives ation method on the t SQ
access and all of the amino acids and
the succinyl compounds and acyl
carnitine from dried blood spots can be
detected and quantified using the rivet
ization method on the access however the
access is not quite sensitive enough to
handle the non derivatized method PQ and
another question how many samples can I
rse pro process anytime there's no are
limitations in terms of the number of
sample processed by our a pro software
usually the taker three to five seconds
to process more sample Oh depending on
the complex's complexity of the
calculation if you want to process how
you go sample at a time so you better to
are also telling a very fast computer
with high capacity of the city universe
thank you um we may have time for just
one more question that you post this one
can I RC pro be used for processing raw
data acquired from other vendor
instruments no I RC pro can only process
the data acquired from a thermo
scientific
q triple quadrupole mass spectrometer
Jay thank you another one it's IRC pro
open sourced I know the asteroids are
not of exhaust okay thank you see and we
can give our audience a moment to post
more questions if they would like to
otherwise we may close out you see more
questions may be coming in so I'm just
going to give you the opportunity if you
would like to ask another question and
just keep you that moment otherwise we
will you will close out for today okay
you know I think we will close today and
you will have another opportunity to to
get more information I want to thank the
audience for their interesting questions
and participation in today's events we
will respond in writing to questions we
did not get to today would also like to
thank our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through August 2015 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay when you invite you to for
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's lives then see
you next time bye